qui est vraiment pierre nicollier
présentent-ils une double personnalité
comme il le prétend lui même calme et
posée lorsqu'il est à jeun et violent
lorsqu'il a consommé de l'alcool et du
cannabis
pourtant les experts n'ont pas décelé de
troubles psychiques
et puis il y a le passé de l'accusé une
première condamnation à 20 ans puis
beaucoup d'autres pour des faits de
petite délinquance dans une vie
d'errance sociale un parcours chaotique
dont se sont emparés des parties civiles
c'est clairement une montée en puissance
c'est un touche-à-tout le casier fait
état d'infractions aux biens
d'infraction aux personnes et ça se
termine par un crime abominable devant
la cour d'assises pour l'expert
psychiatre qui est un nicollier a
tendance à rejeter systématiquement la
faute sur les autres à ne pas assumer
ses responsabilités il a aussi de
surprenant trous de mémoire évasif
lorsque le président lui demande de
s'expliquer sur son déferlement de
violence sur virginie nico c'est un coup
de folie dira-t-il pour seule réponse
qui s'explique pas ce qui s'est passé le
soir des faits comment il en a pu
arriver là et pour lui la seule
explication
effectivement logique ça serait un excès
de colère et puis comme si c'était plus
lui-même en fait qu'il était devenu
complètement fou et qu'il n'a pas pu
s'arrêter
malheureusement en 2015 virginie nico
avait porté plainte mais avait refusé de
se faire examiner une femme souvent
malmené par un homme violent mais qui en
huit ans de relation avec pierre
nicollier n'aura pas réussi à se séparer
de son bourreau un dossier symptomatique
des violences conjugales pour l'avocat
général
l'enjeu ne porte pas tant la sur la
responsabilité que sur la volonté ou non
de tuer en demandant la réclusion à
perpétuité
l'avocat général répond en partie à
cette question